[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to 2018 yay
so this is a new kind of class and it's
called strategy session and today on
strategy session I will show you how to
be the London this is actually part of
my new year's resolution to render this
London system into a London defense for
white
alright so D four out of six night a 3G
six can someone help me with the first
few hundred moves from white yes yes
Bishop f4 Shiv g7 no d3 is not possible
III yes d6
yeah yes so Bishop d3 Knight d2 what are
we going to look at this from a
theoretical point of view this time and
my threat with black is to play this
Knight h5 jump and then just to continue
with age 5 g5
so if you don't play Age 3 let's say you
play Knight d2 I get to play Knight h5
and after Bishop g5 age 6
I get to trap your Bishop and get the
bishop there now that's the reason
Kamsky and others following his
footsteps play h3 Castle c3 c5 many
people who first encountered this
opening I'm meaning the London system
with black usually go for this idea of
'if I've I mean this idea of a 5 but
it's not quite good here as it would
just improve the scope of this Bishop
this Bishop on f4 and would have this
powerful grip on this long diagonal
later
so therefore c5 is the good move and
it's an ex clamp does you should be
pushing on the Queen side with black now
I'm just going to first show the first
boring lines that white can play it's
not that not much fun but we have to
deal with those D takes c5 d takes the
c5 takes rook takes d8 Bishop c7 now
this looks very equal for the untrained
eye yet black might have slight issues
what could be those slight issues that
black could face what is a little bit
over advanced for black
yeah well yeah the bishop has the whole
diagonal but that wasn't a point the
point was that the pawn on c5 is a
little bit overextended and could become
weak
so rook d7 we're chasing away the bishop
bishop h2 but actually that was the aim
of this bishop sortie anyways he wanted
to have our oak in this awkward position
so therefore that plays rook d8 which is
kind of a paradoxical idea but the point
is if black would play knight c6 while
my good Bishop b5 and that could be
uncomfortable so rook the 892 and knight
c6 now a4 and now black plays Bishop f5
this should be 5 is a line played by
Kamsky option but Knight e4 is fine g4
takes takes Bishop e6 now I'm sure you
wonder why white wouldn't take on c6
well that would just open up this
diagonal on the B line and that would be
to an advantage of black and with these
two bishops hitting the black Queen side
this position is more than enough
compensation for the doubled pawns so
comes key castles rook c8 rook g1 a6
takes rook takes c6 and this position is
equal this was played between Kamsky and
Dobrev but blacks plan is to go rook c8
b v b4 and just to advance on the Queen
side this position is roughly equal
because of the bishop there and the
advantage on the Queen side for black
that's one of the ways a for Bishop f5
or white could play g4 here and this
happened in the game between Kamsky and
Gordievsky so this was so g4 was played
and here we have to make a strategic
decision which I'd like you you viewers
and viewers here to find this is kind of
a closed position very typical of the
London system the first question that
comes up is which piece is worth more in
closed position the bishop or the night
the night so here black has to decide
what he wants to exchange for what yeah
Bishop e4 is very good and that's what
Gordievsky played the idea being he
wants to exchange the bishop for the
night and in closed positions in the
long term that book that will favor him
so Knight takes e4 Knight takes e4
Bishop g2 rook c8 a5 and Gordievsky
found a very nice idea in this position
can you please raise your hand if you
have an idea yes c4 that's interesting
but it gives away the d4 square
yeah yes exactly and if I take back
mm-hmm yeah yes and this is exactly what
happened in the game now black played b5
8 XV 6 8 eggs b6 and black has a lot of
compensation here as these pawns will
start strolling down and in the game it
eventually ended in a draw after not
much of a fight in like 10 moves it all
boils down to an equal position so all
in all this is the basic thing you need
to know just before you start playing
this system against the London Bishop g7
d6 castles c5 this is kind of the Tobiah
position you need to know with black and
after D takes D takes take take bishops
e7 group d7
Bishop h2 the key move is rook d8
noticing noticing that white is aiming
to put the bishop on b5 so just avoiding
this idea of the pin and after an ID to
knight c6 a for Bishop f5 black is just
fine now let's look at some games and I
know you'll be surprised why am i
showing a game played by Korchnoi
against beluga you have ski when he's
white well you'll see because he
actually nails down the concept you need
to know to play this setup with black so
Knight f3 Knight of 6 g3 Bishop g2 c6
castles Bishop f5 d 386 and if you would
turn the table around this might seem
familiar right
it's the London system reverse yeah
so basically Korchnoi is playing the
line I'm recommending for you so what
should my play in this position
yeah yeah see four of course v6 and now
the difference is you were looking at
lines with reversed colors when black
was taking on c4 right takes takes this
lines we were looking at these kind of
lines with a tempo up right but now
black decides to play c6 and the first
question is how should we attack blacks
position what would be our first thought
which is the weakest spot in blacks
position yep
the b7 b7 pawn is extremely weak
yeah Queen b3 is an idea the only issue
is with P and B 3 the black can play
Queen b6 and then it's roughly equal now
Korchnoi I also realized that and
thought hmm if I could stop black from
playing Queen b6 and then I could play
Queen b3 I might just have a remarkable
position yeah
Bishop e3 yes because if my place Queen
b3 now then Queen b6 Bishop e3 and takes
takes a 6 and this is an okay position
for black therefore corner came up with
this idea of Bishop e3 which will be key
with black as well so this is the key
concept of the whole setup I'm
suggesting Bishop e7 Queen b3 means c8
Knight c3 Castle rook c1 and now we can
see that Mir in total domination right
now because this pawn is threatening to
take on c5 while the black Queen is an
x-ray and also black will have a hard
time moving around
Bishop 8 7c takes d5 he takes d5 and
mite has a dominating position but is
one weakness enough to win a game no we
need to open up a second front to
actually win so Korchnoi thought about
it and came up with a good solution
played Bishop d4 after should these six
Bishop d6 Bishop d4 what is my preparing
in this position what yeah II for yes of
course
what is preparing the idea of e4 and if
white would get these pawns rolling on e
for an f4 it's just a matter of time
when he will win bishop c7 and whenever
tactics work for you that means you did
something right so c5 would generally
win a piece in positions like this but
because of this x-ray set up by this
rook night thinks d5 works and white is
just dead winning so bishops e7 e 4
takes takes Knight a six-night c4
already hinting at ideas of a 597 now
always look for counter play from black
what is black kind of preparing that
this 97 move
yeah 95 is one of those ideas Black is
preparing but there's a sneaky sneaky
Slav like idea hiding in this position
as well yeah b5 is a very good idea
black is actually threatening b5 the
idea of rolling down the c5 c4 so for
example if I will play rook F d1 here
b5 could come nigh d2 and c5 and black
could get some kind of counter chances
although it's a little bit risky because
these pawns can get a little bit beat a
little bit weak but b5 is a threat so
therefore Courtley played a for stopping
all these tricks and as you said Knight
c5 comes
but fortunately was prepared for this
and play the Queen a3 and usually the
Queen stands stupidly on day 3 but in
these type of positions the Queen is
more comfortable putting pressure on the
d6 Square and the c5 Knight rather than
hiding behind the pawns this c8 Queen is
much much worse than this Queen which is
kind of comfortable on a three right now
96 Bishop e3 obviously we don't want to
give away our bishops because they're
very important in these open positions
and this is a huge opening triumph for
white and we're kind of dreaming of such
a scenario when we are Black Knight b6
95 I mean with reverse colors of course
I'd be 695 tremendous tactical idea by
Korchnoi Knight takes takes
well if takes with the pawn can go eat
eggs d5 Knight g5 and d6 the bishop
cannot move because Knight b6
and if Knight takes e4 I just take back
and if Bishop takes then takes takes and
I take I take and I have a very nice
bishop pair in this position or I could
maybe even take first and play d6
both positions are very good for white
so Knight takes e4 happened rook takes
e4 Queen d8 I'd see 1767 now we have the
nice little bishop pair and oh and a bit
of upon majority on the Kings side B for
green e7 green C 3 group d8 f 4 notice
that just because why it has so much
space he can do apart basically anything
he can advance on both sides while also
kind of dampening this Bishop on h7 that
is dampening this Bishop I have sex b5
what's the idea of p5 because that's an
aggressive move with a strategic idea
behind it can anybody explain what is it
yeah he's trying to weaken the CSIs c6
square and it's also a minority attack
so C takes 8x b5 and now we have a
control of a pivotal square which one
did we get which is so important the d5
square this will be very useful later on
rook d7 rook c8 takes takes Knight a
faith Queen C for uni sex takes takes
now actually this position could be
already winning for white and somebody
tell me why could we say this up front
yes that's one of the reasons yeah
yeah so basically we have plenty of
plans on hitting on this pawn on a seven
on this pawn on a seven and B seven
while also having the advantage of the
bishop pair right yeah so takes it's
already a pawn bishop age 392 King III
and now black out of desperation goes
for this Night Journey
but it won't last long rook d1 and the
deadly threat of rook d8 is fairly hard
to pair very very hard to parry g5 from
the 8th Bishop c5 gtex G takes Bishop g6
and black resigned which is
understandable as the simple route d7
check is winning King h8 and I just take
b7 so what we learned from this game if
you're able to force your opponent Queen
Queen on the first rank you might be
able to get an advantage now let's see
if this is possible to do with the black
colors Black's mistake was playing
passively what white played a perfect
game so this game is between Kamsky and
Joe Benjamin g6 Bishop f4 same old
London that is gonna get refuted now III
h3 c5 notice he Joe Benjamin that black
starts to attack the center as quickly
as possible
because F after D takes e5 here we have
a stronger move than D takes e5 Queen a5
v check the logical move and after c3
Queen takes e5 white just haven't has an
equal position but black is fairly
comfortable here so C 3 C takes d4 I'm
already putting pressure on this
structure e takes d4 and now castle
Bishop e2
and here Joe Benjamin finds the move
that will put why didn't big trouble and
it's more of a strategical way of
playing this position yes Queen b6 and I
play Queen b3 that will not work any
ideas how I could do damage to White's
position here using the strategic plan
that we just learned with reversed
colors yeah we should be six and the
ideas the simple thing of taking away
the be three square castles Queen b3 and
there's no more opposition that would be
so useful for white mean c1 Queen c2 is
an idea but that could run into 4 into
tricks like knight c6 92 rook c8 and
let's say after rook e1 jumps like night
b4 and even this nice little trick of
Knight takes d4 because it takes
paintings and pawn takes runs into rook
takes c2 and there's no way of catching
the Queen the Queen just runs away
either to e5 or d5 and also I was
threatening night before so if nothing
else works night before it's still very
strong so calm skeet shows Queen c1
knight c6 Knight a3 rook c8 rook e1
bishop d5
I hope this position is familiar right
now and it won't be surprising if blacks
plan is
b5 yes so black is planning just like in
the aforementioned Korchnoi game to play
e5 Knight C to Bishop e4 Bishop e4 is a
very strong move by Joe Benjamin
threatening with a really nice trap what
is black threatening now the ships let's
say a three green ticks and again we
have this very nice trick of Knight
takes Queen takes d4 so this is a good
thing a good trick to remember Bishop b4
but Kamsky obviously doesn't fall for
that plays Bishop d1 rook e8 now in
general in these kings in the in London
defense positions we have to be patient
because you have to prepare the idea of
ePHI before actually executing it if you
play e5 too early you might actually
lose the pawn this would be a loss of a
pawn right now so black plays a waiting
move and prepares this idea of e5 Knight
g5 Bishop d5 again black doesn't really
want to get rid of his bishop he's
waiting for the right time Bishop f3 and
how should we continue here
one eight six that would have a little
bit weaken our structure structure
because through eight six they take on
d5 95 and our structures a little bit
iffy I think II five should be it was
due time because if you see your
opponent's pieces jumbled up and this
these pieces are quite badly placed at
the moment like these are not ideally
placed that's the moment to strike
so when your opponent's pieces are just
in their initial position they will put
up a fight but when they're scattered
it's just the right time to play e5 done
all right D takes e5 d to xe5 Bishop e3
and notice we generally want to take
with the pawn as if we would take with
the night we would be saddened by this
very weak bond and isolated pawn on d6
so we want to take with the D pawn if
possible Bishop e3 there should we bring
our queen where is six yeah that would
be a little bit too much to bring the
Queen to a six year yeah Bishop e2 would
be a problem
yeah yes Queen c7 just bolstering this
pawn on e5 and this pawn on f7 because
anytime you play rook e8 except seven
point can become a little bit weak so
it's good to bring some defenses there
we should be five ninety five and we can
see that black blacks play triumphed
because we have the majority on the
Kings side as you remember from my
lecture and cousins campaign it's
important to get a majority on one side
so you can't play for a win now in this
case black I mean why it is a bit too
passive to claim anything and can't
really use the majority on the Queen
side therefore like it's better
look the one with the 8 9 f 3e 4y
doesn't back take on e3 well there's no
concrete reason I'm not taking here the
reason I'm not taking here is more
strategic this Bishop is doing nothing
right so I'm not going to exchange it
all so this would help this terrible
piece on c2 to activate and move to d5
which I don't want to help as black
right
so that is why Benjamin
avoids this exchange it just goes onto
to the offensive 84 91 95 and look at
these mighty beasts on d5 and e5 both
are primarily placed and actually
hinting at other ideas like f5 just
setting up a base on the center so white
is in trouble here right because all of
his pieces are just on the second and
first rank
Bishop h6 but here Joe Benjamin spotted
a fantastic resource for him it's black
to move and then
III I'll take with the bishop yep pieces
can go backwards that's the trick of
chess
in fact the moment you look at this
position what white is overextended
weren't you saying Knight takes on c3
yes can you repeat yeah yeah so if the
pawn would take which didn't happen then
black could take on d1 for stakes and
Bishop takes h6 and black is a healthy
pawn up now white is forced to take on
d8 and here comes the most important
part of blacks combination yep nighty to
check King h1 but if King f1 black still
needs to be careful here and find the
right move
yes rook takes on d8 yes rook takes d8
is the correct move unfortunately if we
take the Queen we get checkmated rook to
x c8 bishop f8 and then Chomsky's idea
would have worked but luckily for black
rook takes d it just works as when white
would take on e to in c4 check King III
and we take the bishop with check and
male most mate there's still f4 but
after he takes after E it's still very
bad for white yeah black wins the Queen
so white was forced to play King h1 rook
takes d8 and now black is a healthy pawn
up again Queen III takes takes Queen b6
double attacking on f2 and b2 now you
can see that the somatic play black
achieved this huge advantage he first
stopped the white queen to enter on b3
and then started rolling slowly with the
idea of rook f e8 and E 5 the game
continued at 93 mean takes me to night C
to 93 pH for Luke d6 black is in total
control here rook f1 Queen f6 so black
has already a huge advantage in material
so he opts for a queen in exchange takes
takes Knight g4 Roxy 693 f5 and
naturally as black is already was
getting ready to promote the pawns on
the King side he's just pushing them and
having the idea of playing f4 III kind
of boxing him although by pieces g3 g5
there's no Knight to f5 because rook
takes c2
day three a four takes takes 95 in yep
seven night B five a six a six is very
good trying to chase away all these
nights which might land the trick
sometimes 97 okay it's six engage - okay
h5f three neither fine
night-night c5 Knight f4 and white
resigned because rook age three it's
hard to parry so in general the game was
very smoothly played by black and the
main idea that you need to remember is
to post your bishop on e6 first and then
go Queen b6 and then you'll be forcing
your opponent to the defensive yes
happened to come ski in this game
I also wanted to show a game which
features the endgame we were talking
about so this was a game played between
Chomsky and Joe Benjamin again so this
is a repetition of the game we just saw
but now this time come ski took on c5
takes rook pin takes d8 rook takes D 892
knight c6 e 4 so this was an earlier
game between the two of them calm ski
didn't played this Bishop c7 idea yet so
he played the instead efore and as
there's no option of Bishop f5 black
goes for the double fianchetto b6 Bishop
b5 should be seven now how would you
calibrate this position
what's your first impression is that
equal slightly better for someone
just guesses yeah mm-hmm
well you could argue that wipe is
slightly better because one central pawn
for example but it's also weakness so
black can play against it too so it's
roughly equal I'd say long castles a six
now White's tragedy is that he can't
make two moves and the e4 pawn is
already committed in these positions we
looked at before the reason we don't
play b6 and we play Bishop f5 instead is
that after b6 Bishop b5 which should be
seven Knights e4 would come and there's
no more a6 because then my could take
and would win upon and there's no root
beer because of this nasty Bishop the
reason why black ops for b6 is that
efore move was all already played b6
Bishop b5 castle a6 bishop a 4b 5c for
now white might be even slightly better
but it's a very pleasant position for
black like has some space on the Queen
side and will try to maneuver the knight
to either e5 or c5 let's see how it
continues rook e1 rook c8 King b1 and 97
Bishop e3 now Mike could opt for a 5 but
even though this is a strength it could
become a weakness as well we could just
go Knight c5 here and I'd say this is
kind of fine for black king b1 Bishop e3
95 takes takes Bishop d4 and here job
Benjamin finds a very nice resource so
remember that even in strategic
positions you should not forget about
tactics they're still part of the game
yeah
Knight to d3 I would just take you
so what's mostly annoying for black is
is this bishop kind of spinning us yeah
yeah Brook takes d4 would be a bit too
expensive if we take on d4 see takes d4
and it's just an exchange so the move
was Bishop h6 a little bit of a move
hitting on d2 and the idea is to play
knight c6 which wouldn't be as pleasant
if we play knight c6 right now because
then he would get to exchange it which
we didn't want to happen
any questions
in repeat I don't hear you yeah yeah
similar to the Queen's Indian this
Bishop h3 and Bishop h6 ideas can work
just like here we should be five Bishop
d2 rook f1 f6 Bishop d4 Bishop f4 so
black had an exposed bishop on d2 but he
could get away with that because he
attacked the e1 rook therefore he has
time to run away
g3 Bishop c7 F 4 and E 5 and now we can
state that black equalised let precise
play but it wasn't that difficult F
takes e5 f takes e5 Bishop c5 so Kamsky
still trying he's putting pressure on
the f8 square takes takes rook the 8th
but Joe Benjamin defends calmly rook f1
Bishop d6 trying to get rid of that
bishop there should be six rook d7 b3 in
g7 King B to ship C six H for Bishop e7
rook f2 and this was an equal position
and after 20 more moves the players
agreed to a draw now before I finish I
want to show another way of dealing with
this system and this game was played in
the philia World Cup between you evolve
and ve the very the young Grandmaster we
all know from China and who played many
many matches by now with the other big
prodigy report Richard now in this game
once again
the London system surprisingly ship g7
III Castle Bishop e2 there's another
method I can advise you to play instead
of d6 e5 if you don't like that you can
always go b6 Bishop e7 and do the double
fianchetto these positions are very
complex and you might as
win these games as it will happen here
h3 there should be seven Castle d6 so
now this is a different concept with the
double fianchetto you can go for the
idea of a six or a five interestingly
you can also play this double fianchetto
system coming from the nimzo-indian so
for example if you play with a six
Bishop f4 b6 III here this should be to
g6 because of the closed nature of the
position you can transpose back to this
line
castles let's say c3 or c4 doesn't
matter black can go d6 plan is Knight d7
Queen e7 e five Knight e4 and f5 and you
have a very very lively play with black
and I think that you could have good
chances of winning now let's see how
this game progresses d6 III Bishop b2 b6
this is a little bit more tactical
because as I showed the other line white
could go for an equal endgame but this
will be a bit more aggressive with more
tactical struggles ahead the 6c 397 92
Queen e8 so we are actually preparing
the idea of e5 if a for how can we react
to that or how should we react to a form
yeah
a 6 yes of course
so if what would go a 5 you would just
push the pawn and wouldn't bother c4
naturally we could consider ideas like
b4 with the plan of
c5 or just takes on c4 but usually after
a 5 B 5 is just a good move so a6 Queen
c2 c5
dei is not deterred he's going for his
aggressive plan D takes e5 d takes e5 we
want this pawn on e5 Bishop a - bishop H
- E for 94 and 95 bringing this piece to
e5 now in general when white as a bishop
on each - we're trying to get rid of all
of these pieces we have on this diagonal
the only exception being this knight on
e5 because it's a it's a very good
locator and we wouldn't mind exchanging
that for that black squared Bishop a5
and the move is b5 of course c4 and now
where he goes gambling but it's totally
justified justified and played before
in general black has an aggressive
position and should have aggressive play
if he would start exchanging that's very
bad because white is playing a defensive
setup every exchange is in his favor his
or her favor so we're trying to
complicate matters here so be for c5
Bishop d5 Queen a4 how should we
continue if you're aiming to attack in
this game should we take on a4 no of
course not
Feenie 7 that's a move in fact that's
what he played mean takes b4 97 putting
pressure on the c5 pawn rook c1 f5 now
very is showing clear intentions
intentions of mating that further ideas
of f4 queen a3 trying to play c6 but we
stopped it with c6 now this turns into a
real Kings Indian kind of struggle that
means black is going for mate and if he
fails that will be
of a big cost so we have to checkmate
Knight c4 in general would be would we
be happy with exchanges should we take
on c4 no of course not
so he plays Knight d3 now the idea of
night d3 is simple he's willing to part
with the pawn in order to open up the
diagonal for the Bishop Bishop d6 now it
takes I would take Queen takes d3 I can
just stick on c5 and have ideas of Queen
g5 and Black has huge play you also have
the bishop pair so Bishop d6 how should
we continue if we play like a master
called me Hart ow
yeah
that would Queen f7 and Queen f6 they're
too slow we have to be very aggressive
very sacrificing material
Queen g5 yes that's the spirit bishop f8
rook takes a faith and notice that black
mostly just takes back material and
doesn't bother much otherwise because
he's aiming to play F 4 and F 3 with
dire with dire consequences for black
for white especially as this F 3 square
will be pivotal Knight b6 Bishop d3
wouldn't be a great idea as he takes d3
would just help our attack and after g3
we could consider queen h5 but F 4 is
also pretty strong so Knight b6 Knight
takes b6 c takes b6 and now black played
night c1 rook c1 and there he spotted
that he can get the advantage quickly
how did he do that
f4f what's a good move but there's a
stronger one you could play him yeah
Bishop takes d4 yeah cuz the rook is
hanging he thinks doesn't work because I
just take and I'm winning
therefore my took the pawn so he's
hoping to have some counter chances with
these pawns which could be the case but
baiii doesn't back down and continues
like nothing happened so it's black to
move and continue with his attack yep
yeah Bishop takes c3 would be a bit
early yeah what did you want to say okay
correct both cuz correct f4 so the idea
of being we don't care about the pieces
we just want an eight so he takes d4 was
played yeah in f3 and again the same
double attack where you double attacks
on both on c1 and on g2 g3 Queen takes
c1 King gauge to Queen d2
game g1 Queen e1 check again and wipe
resigned because King aged 2 losses to
Queen takes f2 and Bishop f1 loses to
Ben Bishop c4 and therefore where you
want his game so all in all coming back
to this position g6 is a very good
weapon against the London system or
should I call it London defense and as
fortunately pointed out in his game
against palooka offski in 1984 you can
aim for this idea of c5 Bishop e2 C
takes d4 C takes d4 eat eggs e4 Bishop
e6 bid the plan of Queen b6 knight c6
and rook c8 and you should be good to go
and should have never any problems
against the London system and I hope
this will help you get this problem out
of your way and Happy New Year is
everyone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]